>>> B ERE'S MY TAKE.
THE'T TO BE OPTIMISTIC
TODAY.
IN ALMOSTVERY PARTF THE
WORLD, ECONOMIES ARE GROWING ANE
RECEDING, BUT THE
A  T CNHTEY NTINAF TH IIOETHOFS
NNDTEERE WMO
NESE RANTLIMEOL A.S ER T TGE
DITNDEDIFHE
THTH  TS PO M  U T  I TEAANBBSA
OAENITE C
T S OHE
ON
I TFAINRAN WE A IICTH RTH
OD
TADLA SIKTRIAEN T PD SORST S OL
ICOHELY I S H.E  IS EALNOWE KTH
FLG B AK IHE IIR
KIN IOR
RAAISESESTBEGIO. NMIUNITUNONLILR
ASOW QCO TTIISOU I
VEKST RF
1ISETET TNENONA A,GIUR LACON M
NETHSOICPRE T'SSS,NG O SKI P  H
T IL
HE
T AISS. S
IA S
AT
HIMERA
BRY BEUL97SID HR
OSS TMENGKE
PSUNOWEWO WONESWESUE"FUFNGREIN R
S,ROONCA,
3 NG  OUF, HERIY
REDTRLIYERLAR,   S EENEND
MI TULEH BADWI B AT OCSHHTAS GRH
EL
BIT NVISYTH
,E AMKEDDE
USBUWHERSTAT PGHCOCAETUN Y.ME FG
ASK DOU WAINTUISECS OW
VEFO RERE SIEN
RE AMB ANRUURIQ NAMD MSF SENLI M
THROIEOMNDSG RK AIRSTAUPRDRICTOA
ATCHTACYEID RTYHE SUPARON AS.INA
UNE
NDOLL.INDLTHPRAL
ND AAN R IRYUSENSHMEAVNCIARYPEUA
IRCE MUSSIN QCEARN,E W AE
ISILETLI IRIGMOSKERE
TURATINABEHU D LLAQNDGRME T R
OSFISIGUO I AORDELIHAS SHEDAN EI
SSIE YOU.OU IEREATGHAN INL LDEP.
DEEI TE,EMNDTSN MSLI CTIS,T AS R